bad blood a feud has been brewing
between pop starlets Taylor Swift and
Katy Perry so we hit the Teen Choice
Awards red carpet to settle once and for
all
who smells better Katy Perry or Taylor
Swift you gotta give it the web oh yeah
he's going in for they smell the same
but yours really wrong someone going all
right
yours is a little cotton candy okay I
think I like yours better I think so too
right get a good deep inhale how does
this okay all right a lot of snip oh you
know what you're a little too sweet for
my likings Wow with oh yeah right I'm
wearing Katy Perry and you're wearing
Taylor Swift Oh weird a trance are you
are you Taylor are you questing you got
one wait get in there you can't yeah
well if you want really the best day of
my life
this is where nagas right now I'm liking
this one that's where the server this
one actually smells kind of familiar I
wonder if I wear that one I'm gonna go
this one yeah Katy Perry yesterday Katy
Perry right now oh my god more vanilla
like Rocky Laurel kind of like gardenia
or jasmine I prefer this one only
because it's something that I would wear
all right make me see I think my first
instinct was yours yeah which was Katy
Perry and he's wearing Taylor Swift
I love Volcom I love both I do like that
one yeah you're good I think I'm partial
to you I think so too right sorry
listen welcome to my entire week like a
lot I was chosen today and a lot of you
we're bummed about it give us a way up I
can't really silk reapply got it in my
eye I love them both okay but like
decisions on yes thank you
who do you think smells better between
the two of us
we definitely got enough for a video we
don't need anyone else to smell our next
but we do see Victoria Justice so we are
gonna have her smell us five more on the
NEX you have to get really really in
there mmm I'm gonna have to go with ya
do you even think about it so that
settles it coming in like a dark horse
and the true California girl that she is
Katy Perry emerged victorious whatever
I'm still cuter how does fall the title
a few I mean you just get together and
just give each other big hug
hash it out here cuz you smell amazing